oh my homegirls in my head all of those
ladies by the way and my girlfriend
group I was always Miranda but I know
you guys have all heard the speculation
of a third Sex in the City movie right
well lately that speculation seemed to
be growing the rumored holdout Kim
Cattrall
and today the news that has all us
diehard fans crying in our cosmos Sex in
the City 3 say no go hey Sora
are you a little upset that Kim is
Delaine Sex in the City 3 please tell me
you've changed your mind well not
exactly the headlines blame Kim
Cottrell's outrageous demands and her
always playing the victim for the film
getting the act and I'm done the Daily
Mail TV reports the 61 year old wanted
Warner Brothers to produce some projects
she had in development or she wouldn't
commit the studio said no way yes
financially it would be fantastic
for all of us but I'm really about
content Kim tweeted her response the
only demand I ever made was that I
didn't want to do a third film please
easy there waterworks
SJP Cynthia and Kristen had all
reportedly signed on Kristen posted this
morning quote I am sad and disappointed
that we won't be able to bring you all
the final chapter of Sex in the City I
would want to do it I'm on record like
it is the gift that keeps on giving
there are warming drawers that keep the
plate warm I say it's not on the table
it's in the warming drawer I think we
could remain hopeful as for mr. big
Chris Noth kind of think that stories
told many times I think it's over so
what now
well SIA may have found a solution
the singer tweeted can I just play
Samantha and we give the people more sex
in the city we'll just pretend I had
lots of plastic surgery for the right
we're just gonna have to go back to
watching our box set of seasons 1
through 6 I do own it Kelty night and I
watch it a lot
[Music]
you